feminists can sometimes
be so feministic that they want to be a
man i'm thinking men and women are equal
but they're not the same yeah
hi i'm sean reynolds and i'm still on
the lookout i've had some good dates i'm
liking my views let you know what i'm
saying it's all good right now charm
aren't ya and i've had some bad dates
how do you think you've done on the date
i don't really give a [ __ ] i'm not gonna
lie about it where are all the decent
men not in my dms that's for sure you
get me i feel like i'm rolling with the
man then what's going on about your
fives it seems like a lot of men don't
know how to treat a lady i'll just
manhandle everything and this girl's
putting a chest and chest in the nut
like
will i have better luck this season what
would you do if my ex was after you he
can have you let's find out this
is grilling
my name's tyler mitchell and i'm here to
have a date with cheyenne
she wants to grill me well i'm a boxer
so we're used to the heat we're used to
being good so i'm not nervous excited
intrigued yes you can ask me whatever
she likes
whether i get put off by what she asks
it depends what she asks and how she
asks it i think i like a classy woman
with decorum so there's a way to go
about things but we'll see how it goes
on and i'll know after if i get put off
or not now i don't date it's not it's
not something i don't quite recluse when
it comes to things like that so
they're out of my comfort zone but
pressure makes diamonds as you see yeah
always open to a relationship if you
find the right person
then that's the ultimate goal nobody
wants to be single forever do they so
if you find someone that you connect
with then yeah a hundred percent of
relationships
are you ready yeah bomb ready come on so
we do bone ready any situation anything
in life you're ready
hello hi hi all right yeah good thank
you how are you i'm good thank you i'm
good and good what's your name hi
nice to meet you cheyenne nice to meet
you
now he seems really cute clean looks
clean where are you from i'm from derby
do you know
and then where is it it's like
east mids so it's like in between
like near nottingham oh really so why
not myself oh um not too far in the
essex shout out yeah
difficult
no you don't know you don't you don't
you don't yeah yeah yeah yeah i know
she's beautiful and she yeah she's a
beautiful girl she seemed kind of seen
as polite so yeah good good impression
it's higher temperature
um i'm a boxer yeah and that's all i've
ever really done to be honest so i'm a
boxer i'm 31 years old
i love a boxer what about yourself i
create content um
i do charity events i
spend time with my friends my family
like the usual what do you do for fun um
i do a lot of sports so i play golf and
play tennis i do a lot of sports i hang
out with my family i'm a really big
family person who are you yeah so i like
to spend time with my family yes he's a
family man
um and i also run a charity
um so yeah we've got we've got that in
common nice tell me about your charity
um it's called get heard
um and it's just about
street violence and stuff that's in the
stream trying to show people that
there's another way to live life and
you know i mean there's more avenues and
i feel like especially today with social
media saying things are glorified and if
and especially the youth are quite
influenced they might try and follow the
crowd with certain things you know
easily influence when you're younger so
i'm just trying to stop people going
down the wrong way because i feel like
everybody's got a talent and they they
don't always fulfill it and i feel like
everybody's got a talent and a passion
for something so i'm just trying to
steer them into the right direction
instead of the roads and that i really
love that yeah thank you oh i love this
big green tick absolutely what
influenced you to do that i've obviously
i've gotta pass myself and i feel like i
made mistakes in the past myself
there's things i've done i'd regret i'd
like to change but i can't so i thought
well if i can't change my past what's
the best thing to give
to
lead the best future i can and i feel
like if i can change even one kid's life
by trying to steer them to the right
path then i find that quite fulfilling
so i'm quite passionate about it
and i'm trying to push it through my
boxing as well so i think my boxing can
help definitely shed a light on things
and i just feel like just trying to put
some positivity and some good things
back into the woods yeah that's amazing
yeah thank you are you not drinking no i
don't do normally you don't drink
oh okay yeah i feel like i'm not going
to drink i don't want to drink that's
fine you can drink no
you know i feel like we agree on a lot
of stuff so
like mcdonald's she's meant loving it
you get me oh he seems really nice um
how come you're single good question
i'm not sure not by really any like um
i'm not trying to be single i'm quite
picky and particular on
the kind of woman that i like um and i
just haven't come across them yet and i
just don't want to force anything i'm
not somebody that forces things you know
i mean so i feel like when the right one
comes along i'll be open to it but until
then i'm not just going to settle
because i feel like when you settle it's
never going to work in the long run and
i try and invest properly if i'm going
to do it like that so what do you look
for in a woman i don't know so looks
wise i don't really have a type i don't
know i don't have a type of luxuries i
literally find beauty you know women i
feel like it's more on how they help
themself and how they act um i like kind
kind women you know women are just
generally you can tell you're not trying
to put on a persona for to attract the
man you're actually genuinely going to
care about your friends your family i
don't want nothing from a woman so how
much money she has doesn't concern me
but i like a woman that has goals and
aspirations in life
um so that's important to me because
obviously i
have goals and aspirations and i'd like
to meet someone so then we can build an
empire together um i still wouldn't want
nothing from you i'd take care of
everything because i'm quite traditional
like that my man but at the same time as
if my woman had wanted like a business
or something i'd help her fulfill her
dreams also because she can have dreams
outside of the relationship her personal
dreams like that so because you leave
you believe in traditional do you think
that puts pressure on you to then be a
man i don't think it's pressure because
i don't know any different i just feel
like that's what a man should do and i
also think that's what a woman i find
i'm unattractive i feel like
i'm all for equal rights with men and
women but i feel like people i think
sometimes feminists can sometimes
be so feministic that they want to be a
man i'm thinking men and women are equal
but they're not the same yeah don't know
and a woman will be submissive to a man
if he um follow a man if he knows where
he's going i feel like a lot of men
don't have direction these days so they
don't know where they're going and i was
a woman gonna follow her man i don't
know where she's going
i might preach that and obviously i
treat my woman like a like a princess if
she's a woman i don't it's cool being
having this bad boy image i get that to
a certain extent you should still treat
your wife like a queen yeah absolutely
the way i say is you should treat your
woman i want to treat my wife
so good that every woman is jealous
about how good i treat her that's my
plan you know i mean that's how i see it
i don't like his plan he talks a lot of
sense
yeah yeah
i don't like you see if people are
laughing at you behind about you know
certain people and they could be acting
a bit mad when they're not with a girl i
don't want that i think that's
disrespectful because you wouldn't treat
your friends like you wouldn't have
known enough about your friends you
shouldn't have known i think your woman
yeah listen that's what i mean no one's
making my do you think i'm making my man
look stupid yeah exactly that's all you
need so what do you look for in a man
you know what i look forward to
stability yeah i look for honesty
loyalty
and that's it really i don't look for
too much but i just kind of feel like
everything does complicate it when like
you try a date online or you try and
meet people because i feel like everyone
comes with like their
their persona like this is who i am and
this is my image kind of thing but when
you actually get to it it's hard to find
just people like so many people lack
just basic like skills like even just
like honesty for example it's not a
skill but
so many people just lack being honest
you know and that's why i'm just like
these are basics like i shouldn't
glorify this i shouldn't have to look
for this this should just be like
standards you know so i find it hard but
i like funny as well i'm i'm quite like
serious and normal but then once you get
to know me i'm goofy is there anything
like i'm my goofy and i like it when you
when that when my partner would be goofy
it should be like children around each
other because life's quite serious i
feel like obviously there's time to be
serious but you should be
like childish with your spouse and you
know i mean jokes about that stuff yeah
i like that yeah what would be like the
what's the best thing you've done to
impress someone on a date i don't really
date you know you know i really don't
date um at all so this is like of my
comfort zone a bit
don't date
why are you here i don't know i just try
and be myself do you know what it is i
feel like naturally as human beings when
we go on a date you always want to give
the best version of yourself because
you're not going to let them know all
your bad things because you might put
them off that's probably why people lie
a lot
you're always going to you're always
going to look just better than you
always would if you're in a relationship
you're not trying to try and look your
best 24 7.
um but i feel like if you're just
genuinely yourself then there's nothing
that can go wrong down the line because
you can only keep a persona for so long
i've learned that from myself in the
past so what's the worst thing you've
done to try and impress a woman do you
do up all the la lifestyle and stuff um
no not really
these diamonds are blind to me i mean i
have a nice restaurant but like if you
can see like i've only got like this is
from zara i think maybe these dudes are
films i don't i try not to there was a
time where i was really
always because i'm quite insecure so i
have insecurities and i'm trying to
combat them in a minute and i feel like
one of them is
um
money equaling worth and value so i'm
trying to like wear less design and not
wear designer because that's not a
representation of me i'm a good person
with or without designer i like that
yeah i'm just being me you know i'm just
being myself so she likes it she likes
it she does she don't what have you ever
done anything on a date to try and
impress someone
i would just do my best before but
really it's not that impressive when i
look and i think when you get glammed up
and it's like but they're just going
through like you're aesthetic yeah do
they actually like you probably not they
just want to like have sex with you
i feel sorry for women women have got it
hard because i feel like
they really can't find out man's
intentions because they want to know if
i want to sleep with them or not but
even men will even play persona all the
way up until until they slept with them
and then they'll only really know their
true intentions so it's kind of
difficult for women to try and have to
navigate through if i'm unserious or not
yeah me personally i don't care about a
woman's looks i've had
what i believe really beautiful women
try and date me and i'm not interested
because i can see how you act outside of
that and that's not going to work it's
deeper than looks everyone's good
looking these days you know what i mean
it's hard to find somebody good looking
you have to have something more than
that deeper to understand
ty when was the last time you had sex
at the pools yeah a while ago how long's
a while a long while ago i have a past
and i'm completely different now the man
you see now is not the man i always used
to be but i had to go on a lot of
there's a lot i went on a lot of healing
a lot of trying to find myself as a
group i found religion that helped me a
lot
i went for a lot of pain emotionally
with certain things and i felt like that
made me look at myself a lot and i feel
like it's hard to sometimes have a look
in the mirror and have an honest
conversation with yourself but that's
what i had to do to go to try and grow
um i'm a muslim now so we don't really
do this boyfriend girlfriend thing we
get married this marriage first but we
can date we can go out with them etc
meet them
but this boyfriend girlfriend thinks
yeah we don't really do that
so what's like the dating process for
you then there's a big like
misconception that oh you can't see
women and you can't be like as long as
you're in a place say if we went to a
restaurant that's fine because we're
these people that when it's when you two
are left alone that's where
you might fall into sin um but no we can
date and then we can speak and then if
we want to get married we can get
married it's quite marriage is quite
simple in
in islam compared to how it is today i
think even yesterday in our grand
parents time they got made a lot younger
and if you look at our grandparents era
most of our grandparents are together
more people's grandparents stay together
and you don't really hear that many
people's grandparents but then one
generation unless our parents a lot of
people's parents ain't together and now
our generation people are just having
kids and not even never been together so
i'm more of an old school person i feel
like you should keep the traditions good
and treat a woman with respect and try
and
the people are so easy to quit these
days they go for a lot of um difficulty
in relationships and next minute they
want to get split up there's no working
through things anymore i don't agree
with that are you good with
communicating then i think communication
is single-handedly probably the biggest
key in a relationship because
i've learned this from past
relationships without communication
something quite small can be quite
become quite big just because you both
took a different perspective on the same
thing and i feel like if you're honest
and open with each other and you love
each other you can work for nearly
anything but it's all about honesty and
transparency
this is a good day
do you think social media is a reason
why people don't work through things now
100 i think
people don't use social media they like
use them and i feel like
yeah they do they don't use it like i i
was even myself i was always on there
and i'd be looking through stuff all day
and i'm and i still learn that a bit too
much but i still try and come by is like
i try and use it i go and i post what
content i want to post from a boxing or
whatever it is and then come off so i
can use it i don't let it use me social
media man use social media don't let it
use human because it's a it's a dark
rabbit holeman i was in the barber shop
once and a man actually said something
on an old school man said something
really funny always stuck with me he
said you like don't even speak to each
other anymore i said turn off your wi-fi
and turn on your wife and i thought i
was like a gem and i really agree it it
was a good one
we got the old man
years ago when people was going through
hard times they didn't have hundreds of
people trying to dm them that they could
have run off to when things got hard and
chime in their two pens exactly so you
have people chiming in then you have men
will be in your mrs inbox so anytime
she's going for a bad time she's got
other men that she could rely on and
vice versa with it and i just feel like
yeah it's not i don't
i think if you use it right social media
is a good thing but as long as you don't
let it use you
how about have you had long-term
relationships yeah i've had one
long-term relationship
and i've had like a couple of exes okay
what would your ex's say about you
depends which one you ask them when
like i said i went for a journey myself
of um having to like i said i have an
honest conversation with myself i feel
like i let a lot of childhood traumas
shape who i was and i just thought you
know what it's time to break the cycle i
can't
let this go on to the next generation of
my kids and stuff like that so i had an
honest conversation with myself my exes
i think they would say i'm a good person
though they might have said i had issues
and i had real issues with trusting and
like taking to women because i have real
by trust issues um but i think they'd
say he's a good person and his heart's
in the right place and i was always
right to them i never like
you know i mean i was never abusive to
them or nothing like that i've never
ever done that to any female in my life
seems like a good person it's like
you've gone on a good journey i try i
try
definitely everyone could be a bit
better but i try what would your ex say
about you oh i'm really good i'm really
not close like that but i'm on really
good terms with all of my exes
um
yeah they're actually because i wish my
exes could actually speak about me
because they all speak really highly of
them okay that's good that's good how
would you feel about me going to dinner
with my ex with me together yeah no
that's why i would dinner with your ex
are you mad yeah not any of me no my
words no chance even if your intentions
are
strictly pure i could bet my bond and if
you tried to say i didn't come back to
mine we'll get together he'd say yes
it's not your intentions it's his
intentions
even if his intentions wasn't the same
like if you switched and said to him
i'll come let's go back to miami let's
just do it one last time you'll go
because it's just a psyche of a man you
once you was once attracted to each
other so you shouldn't even be putting
yourself in a situation like that i i
feel and i feel like you'll be
disrespectful towards me and i'll never
do it to you do you know what i mean and
if you spend too much time with somebody
alone
it's a psyche of a male and a female
even if if you know people they might
work together for years they had no
attraction to each other but when you
spend too much time with someone
attraction can start to bubble again so
yeah i wouldn't find that acceptable
yeah
how would you feel if i went on
if i if it was the opposite way around i
was like i'm just going to go meet max
for dinner i'm quite comfortable with
who i am as a person as women as
someone's partner and i think it just
would depend on like the kind of
relationship that you had with your ex
if that makes sense because i feel like
i never really elaborate on why i'm
friends with my exes and stuff and it's
you know like a lot of them help me
through trauma and so we have this it's
like just this respect for each other
like they saved me through hard times
and so that's why for me it would be a
shame to look past them and just not
really acknowledge them so it's a lot
different it's not like everyone else's
relationship where they've just broken
up like it was it's a lot deeper than
that so that's why i understand that i
feel like
you wouldn't if you see him in the
street you wouldn't expect i wouldn't
expect you to just walk past them even
if i was with you do you know what i
mean you could say hello but i feel like
you didn't you could still speak maybe
if the message on social media is
everything okay you message but yeah
that's fine thanks and then done but i
feel like going to dinner and it's open
up something that doesn't need to open
up i think like it's a bit too intimate
how many women have you slept with
it's like i said yeah
i had a past yeah but that's not a
dictation of who i am now are you
avoiding eye contact did you say this
because i'm trying to think like
i've not slept with that well i've not
slept with loads but i've not slept with
like not loads either
he's lying
so
but now i don't do that
i don't do none of that now so
if we had to say
a number yeah
quite a high one but like i said as i
ordered me let's talk about the news i
don't know i don't know that i don't
know for me like
i how many many have you slept with no
listen i'm asking
you you're not gonna answer
and don't want to talk about how many
dislike with it's never a good sign
i might answer i might do a little truth
bomb okay i slept with three people how
many people are you slipping three three
is not high
yeah see you're lying are you lying to
me nothing so that one is an honest man
and here you are lying no it's more than
three but i just don't i just don't
think there's um i told you this
the gods on the streets i don't actually
know
depends what you kind of like
how many people have used that movie
yeah same yeah
a lot yeah has it a lot no
i'm not saying yeah no you know what i
think it's like what is your thoughts on
that women that
have slept with like loads of men then i
don't try and judge nobody on the past i
feel like everybody deserves a chance of
redemption and i feel like if you've
lived a certain life and you want to
change i feel like anybody should be
given a chance to change would i like it
i'll i wouldn't like it personally from
if i was but would i be completely
against it like i said i always try and
give people the chance you know i mean i
think it depends on how she is as a
person when i meet her because i feel
like anyone can have a person like i
said i'd rather meet someone that hadn't
slept with a lot of people because i
wouldn't like to be there and like save
me and you've gone out and be in the
room and it's not even an insecurity in
me that i've only been missed it's not
really an insecurities the fact is as
men we like to feel like respected and
we like to feel like a man likes to feel
like that like a man as a man we have
pride and things like that and i feel
like if you're with a female she should
only increase that and make you feel
good and think yeah no one can say and i
feel like if everyone in the club slept
if it kind of decreases that yeah you
know i mean his wife should make him
feel proud and vice versa you have more
pride as a man when men haven't been
with her but men are going out sleeping
with a lot of women so they have to also
hold themselves accountable like if men
really valued women as much as they say
they do then they wouldn't sleep with
just women so pointlessly like men sleep
around like women can as well but you
know what i mean like it's more likely
you've slept with 100 people than i have
but you're saying that men value women
they want you you want to be the one
that's proud and hasn't had a woman
that's stuck with anyone like i said men
and women are equal but they're not the
same and that's not me saying that men
should be able to live with women and
that's not what i'm saying i feel like
like i said we have different psyches so
like most if you like i can imagine if
you go to 100 men and ask them would you
mind how many people your partner slept
with 99 of them would say yeah a lot of
them would say yeah i'd care and most
women wouldn't care that's because men
and women even though they're equal the
psyche is different
when you say yeah if they've respected
women while they're sleeping with so
many i feel like men respect women that
respect themselves genuinely i find if a
woman's just giving up easy a man won't
have respect for her so he won't treat
her with respect but if a woman respects
yourself saying no i'm not just going to
free up to you i'm only going to sleep
with you if i got feelings for you if
we're together in a relationship he will
treat her with respect but if you've not
got respect for yourself then how am i
going to respect you i try and treat
your woman with respect regardless but i
understand when women get treated
disrespectfully because you don't even
respect yourself do you know i mean yeah
but would it not be the same like if
manchester's trying to sleep with me i'm
like do you not have respect for
yourself 100
yeah i feel like if a man is just trying
to save you he should yeah he should
have more self-respect that's why i feel
like
marriage is always better then you know
your intentions you should always be
commit to each other before you sleep
with each other and then all this
wouldn't be happening i like that see
have you got a bit of an accent it's
like a bit of a twang darby i don't know
i feel like we don't have an accent so i
feel like we speak normally but i feel
like everybody else has next time but i
don't feel like you have much of a
different accent to me though no you
know what if um i drink
yeah i get really common okay i think
like love
yeah it's funny it's grown on me it's a
bit of a dark horse what got you into
boxing
um so my dad was a professional boxer
when i was i was young at the time he
was hard when i was like seven i think
or was as i was six or seven he was a
heavyweight though i'm only a super
middleweight song quite a bit lower but
then yeah so when he retired from boxing
he set up his own gym called one nation
and i started amit so i started training
when i was like seven and then yes i've
just basically been in and then i was
there turned pro i did some unlicensing
like semi-pro boxing and then yeah i'm
just going back into pro boxing again
now
yeah so
that's my boxing genie but i look i i
really look to really put my um my foot
down this next couple of years really
go in see what i can get
and then hopefully we'll get to the top
nice nice nice so did you go clubbing
and stuff yeah sometimes i shouldn't um
but i do sometimes obviously i just
don't drink when i go um but it's that
how do i get it's just not for me i'm
normally the one to leave first so i
might go
realize i'm not missing nothing and then
leave but you know what i do i maybe i'm
gonna sound so old
but i just crave peace so much more than
anything like people want all these nice
things and this and i just created peace
so like i like to just say on sunday
morning i like to like maybe go for a
walk in the countryside because i'm like
a real country bunker like my worst
place to live is somewhere like london i
don't like busy places i don't like
loudness i'm quite um
a calm chilled out person
maybe because of my professional stuff
maybe because it's quite intense my
profession i just like to you know i
mean i like to spend a lot of time with
my grandparents spend time with my son i
like to just do things that is quite
fulfilling inside you know i mean i just
feel like clubbing and that doesn't
fulfill me okay so if i was trying to
impress you what would be the best thing
i could do to take you on a date sliding
the dms like yo baby lotion i like you
now i don't know maybe i
rate to say if you was interested in me
i like i wouldn't find it point enough
if you used to message me and stuff like
that i feel like some women think i'm
not doing that like i i rate that if you
like someone and let them know i would
let someone know if i like them i feel
like a first date i don't like real
serious first dates like you know when
you decide i like to do something maybe
go arcades go bowling i don't paint but
something kind of fun where you can kind
of it's not too serious you can kind of
have a fun day and get to know each
other but i'm guessing you're
competitive though yeah no i'm not i'm
not letting you win nothing no i'm
competitive yeah no i don't let nobody
win anything whether it's
a child an old person
if a child wants to race with me and say
oh come on something running away i'm
running four fours you're not beating me
if you win you've got to earn it
no yeah i might let you win a point
where you're not going to win the
overall game so if you're getting
smashed and i say yeah you can win a
little i'll let you have a little strike
well then i'm coming back with four
strikes no you're cheeky yeah no i know
nothing
yeah i think she's feeling me you know i
think she likes me i say that now she
better give me a high score excuse me
like a six i'm leaving the country
gone if i was to ask you on a second
date what would you say where are we
going
where do you want to go oh
we can go to an arcade so i can meet you
but then you're just not gonna have a
good date because you're not gonna win
but okay i'll tell you what for this
one's because you're special i might let
you win if you go to the arcade so if i
say let's go to the date to the arcades
what you're saying yeah we'll go you
like that yeah yeah yeah yeah we'll go
okay then i'm gonna keep you to that all
right let's do it
listen let's see how to take guys number
two so what do you teach your son
like in what aspect like just in life
yeah
i've tried to learn from
whatever i've gone through as a kid and
things i've experienced and obviously my
father and his grandpa i think
everything comes down and everyone we
can only try and do better do better
than what we've been taught but i'm
like my arm had absolutely addicted to
my son like he's like every atom of my
being i can't even explain it like he's
my world and i feel like
even though my parents loved me and
stuff i wasn't really close like
i never got shown that kind of love
going like i don't leave my son alone i
kiss him like 100 i can't let you know i
mean he's like six now and he's getting
a bit annoyed at me
but i feel like it's good to show a lot
of love and affection and i just want
him to be and he is luckily he's such a
nice kid like he's dead kind he's dead
like it's quite mellow like me
i have him half the time
and i feel like i am a good dad when men
are present fathers i think it's so
attractive like there's nothing more
attractive than the man just like
holding himself accountable and stepping
up to you know
his kids and i'm the best that i can be
but also have to give props to his mum
he's got such a good mum like we're not
together what we co-parent well and she
allows me to be the father i am by being
easy with me i feel like i feel sorry
for a lot of women
that have baby before i was like drama
and vice versa i feel like if you love
the kid i feel what we have in common is
we love our kid more than anything so
that gives us both the um the chance to
be good parents and it works so well
yeah and he's got the best mom so i'd
never knock her you know i mean she's
she's a really good one baby mum's baby
does i feel like even that room's a bit
derogatory the son of my mum i feel like
people
these days is very toxic isn't it i feel
like we should show love respect
especially these women when they do a
good job with these kids you know i mean
with our kids so yeah i feel like
they're not spoken about enough man we
should respect and revere our women
that's really amazing
like it's really nice to hear as well
like especially from a male's
perspective someone
speaks so positively about that mother
of their child because i find like you
hear it too often like people are like
oh baby mama drama and stuff like that
so it's very refreshing i feel like when
we first split up there was obviously
there was a bit of back and forth and
this and that but then we very quickly
came to the realization is anything that
we go through we can't let that affect
him because
we think that children see nothing but
they see everything and we split when he
was really young but even if we had an
argument we could slightly see a change
in his behavior and we both just nipped
it in the bud and we've grown up as
people as both young men we've grown up
now
and yeah we co-parent really well and i
feel like men should
um celebrate women and let them know
whether it be your auntie your sister
your baby mum just because you're not
together it doesn't mean she's not a
great mum to your child and i feel like
you should
and let her know like let her know
you're a great mum because women need to
hear that i'm meant to but i feel like
they need to hear that and understand
that y'all were respected because it's
not an easy job being a woman especially
a mother it's not an easy job and i
think after having kids it made me
appreciate what my parents had to go
through because it's hard sometimes you
know i mean especially as a single
parent my mum was a single parent of
four and i just feel like i don't know
how you did that do you know what i mean
so no i am i definitely respect her
do you know how refreshing it is to
actually hear a man speak so highly and
positive about the mother of his child
um ty do you eat [ __ ]
yo
wild this is getting out of on this is
the team in a bit we need to tame it in
a bit so what i'm saying is this year i
feel like
i we live in a very hyper sexualized
society right in a minute and i feel
like there's something sacred
i feel like there should be something
kept sacred between what you do in a
relationship i feel like people just
talk about it blasey blase is even to
the point where
a lot of men don't even
get excited in women in nordrane anymore
because most women wear it to the club
these days so i feel like there's
something special in keeping that sacred
having said that there's
whatever my woman would want me to do
i'm down for because i'm i'm pleasing my
woman in whatever aspect she needs
please you know what i mean um because i
wouldn't want her to want to find it
somewhere else first of all and also i
want her to think i'm the bestest ev
ever do you know what i mean so that's
what i'm on but getting into the details
of it i feel like you should try and
keep it sacred between you and your
partner don't worry what i'm doing in
the bedroom get me that's between me and
my wife you don't need to know that yet
you're not my wife so when you if you
are maybe one day you'll find that play
your cards right maybe one day you'll
see so yes then so i'll do anything that
my partner wants us to do
if that's what she's into then maybe
that's what happened
you have to choose one
it depends though on
she can have the password to my phone no
problem as long as i've got the trust to
her that she needs to go into my phone
to get something or do something fair
enough go on my phone but i have to
trust that she's not going to go through
my private messages with me and my
friends because then i might be having a
conversation with my friend they might
be confiding in me or something or a
family member or anybody that's none of
my partner's business yeah password to
my phone
yeah she probably ain't gonna get that
still but she thinks she is though so
we're in i think she is when it comes
down to it so you know what babes i lost
my phone you know i left i left it at
the gym i'll get it for you tomorrow
yeah i think it's just a standard
because i feel like if someone gives you
the password like i've been like oh
nothing to snoop but if someone's like
very defensive i'd be like
what are you hiding yeah exactly i think
like i said it just depends on the
reason and i just let her know if i
trust my wife or my missus i'm not i
just like look
you can have it but there's certain
things don't do and i trust that she
wouldn't go in there anyway and i always
give people shots until they break it
anyway that's how i try and live my life
i don't mind it's not that deep for me
what about you yeah i don't think it's
dp but i think it all depends on the
intention and i just think it's not that
deep i think it likes to like just
because you like a picture doesn't mean
i won't have sex with you doesn't mean i
want to take you on a date it doesn't
mean some people might get like and
immaturely think oh that person likes me
it's not that deep it's like on
instagram it's instagram you know it's
not really madness i find that when i'm
really interested in someone like i
don't want to like anyone else's stuff
yeah like i just want that person to be
like my person and only like their stuff
when i'm in a relationship i don't
follow i don't follow females on
instagram anyway so the only females i
follow on instagram is if it's a work
colleague or someone in the gym or a
family member i don't just follow
females on instagram like i used to but
i stopped doing it because therefore
there's no need for you to help me out
there and i feel like if i was in a
relationship i wouldn't be following
females anyway so i wouldn't have chance
to like the pictures i see i like that
see
men can learn a lot from him you know
yes ty
am i how am i feeling at the moment
no
making good matching yeah apparently so
100 i'm alpha male 1 are you yeah we are
from really alpha really how alpha lion
alpha yeah a lion
really noticed in the bedroom doesn't
like that
just like in life though i'm i am
definitely an alpha male yeah but i not
alpha not like toxic alpha that did good
balance yeah the good balance of alpha
yeah yes he has got the alpha energy
that i like
do you think you could dominate me yeah
like light work you see me
you see how taller
my box i'm strong so it's like good then
yeah but in a nice way though not in
like a you know me
think throw me around
you have to choose one yes for me no for
you why because i see my woman as a
princess so when she's fine around me i
feel like she's one of the lads like yo
i feel like you're like proper you're
princess you're a queen so then when
you're doing that it's gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna find it less attractive you
know what i mean
i know women fight like you're a human
being but i just find it as a kind of
like a male attribute just like wow so
if i want to say for everyone you have
to lift your leg up for fine i was like
i just want you to be able to laugh with
me
first of all
that stinks
second of all i'm going to bed
farting around me are you mad yeah
that's not gonna happen not my wife my
wife's a princess we don't do them
things foresee me
every so often real men
imagine if we were like in bed together
gonna be all sexy and then if i just let
one up would it ah the whole ah
even if i did that it would ruin the
mood i'd ruin it for myself i'll be like
nah i need to have a word of myself yeah
that's the worst place to probably do it
but like say everyone slipped out
accidentally in anywhere like i'm not
gonna be like oh my god you're trying
like you're a human being that doesn't
matter i'll probably laugh at somebody
trump but when you're lifting your leg
up unfortunately when i listen to me
that's not yeah
oh wait a minute god damn it what the
yeah just have to react like that
yeah no not in it
you know what
ah
i say i do now
it used to be nine it's yeah yeah yeah i
do yeah i'm not gonna lie
yeah it bothers me a little yeah it does
like i said i don't wanna
judge no no no pass but it would have an
impact on how i saw them and it's mad
because society has a standard of a man
and a woman and there's all this
feminist stuff going on the most money
if you tell if you're asking me how many
have you slept with
most of them are not really that
bothered about turning you but guess
what man most of them don't want to tell
you and it's not fair but women
subconsciously know that that will
affect how many people they slept with
will affect their value as a woman
because they think you know if i start
with so many people he's going to put
them off of me and it's not fair because
i agree it's not fair it's like what's
the body count limit for you
i really don't know
are you just thinking yeah i'm trying to
think like how many people let me know
yeah no i'm trying no i'm not i'm not
thinking that i'm trying to think how
many would i think and
i don't know because you know what it is
i think it's not so much to do with the
number is to do with
how many people can say it you know i
mean like say if i was out with her and
all these and if i was with someone safe
she lived in
i don't know west africa somewhere where
i'd never met no one and she slept with
a lot of people i wouldn't care because
i think you don't know where that's more
the reason what it is it's not how many
people you slept with it's how does it
make me look oh yeah yeah that's more i
think i think for a male yeah a hundred
percent of body count for me that's wild
if the body counts high yeah
i could say
i wouldn't like it personally anyway
it's a bit crazy that bigger numbers
than me and that wild yourself what's
too many for a man men sleep around a
lot
but i think it's just at a point where
for me if soon someone's just said
they've slept with over 100 people
it does sound a bit mad like i think
even not jake
i think even just like men even over 50
i think is crazy like realistically when
we actually talk about energy exchange
and the reality of it like that is a lot
especially it depends as well because if
you've been in a relationship a long
time then you've only had like a year
how the hell have you slept with 50
people in one year yeah about each of
their own whatever 100 i agree i agree
with you or not i think
i i've only someone who was talking to
me about this
energy exchange every day
and i didn't really understand it um but
when people explain it to me if it's
true i don't know if it's true or not
because i'm not really looked into it
but that's that's probably a reason why
a lot of people are messed up yeah they
probably have a lot to do with it and i
think now everyone's just messed up i
feel like men have treated women like
crap for so long
they're now fighting back thinking right
if you do we're gonna do it too and it's
just not good for anyone i think the
problem
that i personally find is with women
today is they're trying to be like men
and that's taking away your strongest
thing your beauty and your powers that
you're a woman because no matter what i
do i could never be like you are you
know what i mean and i feel like you
being a woman is your power and i feel
like because men and women have treated
each other like [ __ ] so much they just
it's just like a free-for-all now and
it's just you
you
attractive and a female if you get done
dirty instead of trying to doing back or
getting back or slander them say you
know what you messed up you tricked me
like i know i did you good you've
checked me wrong but i'm i know who i am
as a person and then you move on here
and then go and walk out and respect
yourself you don't have to get nobody
back and you're just a good person that
that's why i'm at my moment real good
person because when you're hurt or your
emotions is up your true colors will
come out a lot of the time this guy's
really growing on me i feel like he is
what would be the definition of a man
i think i think with women though we're
just i sometimes like it's just trying
to prove a point like with this whole
hypersexual behavior city girls i know i
say all the time but
the only person that actually gets hurt
and damage is the women and that's why i
never condone and i never preach to
women oh my god do this do that because
really of it is you've now probably
slept with like 20 men and now men don't
rate you yeah you know and the bottom
line is as much as women say we don't
care like we do because this is why it's
such an issue
booty play don't pick up two i'm gonna
take one from you
i'm gonna say yes but i would do to
clarify yeah go on
speak now forever please like obviously
you know i'm playing with my beauty
but i'll if the woman wants to look at
what massage and then things there but
whatever she's like listen that
the woman yeah but i'm a man
ty what's the red flag for you
so
i hate when women try and lie to impress
me so i feel like sometimes you could
speak to somebody and they'll say
something i remember everything so you
say something yeah i remember everything
so like are you missing it
but like when someone says something
about and then they can say something
else i'm thinking well you've just lied
then because last time you said this i
hate stuff like that some even if you're
doing it from a good place and they're
just doing it because they're trying to
impress me whatever i just don't like
when people yeah lie and stuff like that
and just try and make stuff up i hate
stuff like that yeah sure red flakes if
someone's rude to the waiter i hate that
yeah yeah little things like that yeah i
think that's that's also one of mine
just been like i said earlier just be a
kind person man even if someone's not
even kind to me
if someone's not kind to me i don't feel
like i should not be not kind back i
just that their attitude shouldn't
change who you are you know what would
you do if i've slept with two of your
friends i guess if it was before i knew
you before i knew you and his wife would
go
and i liked you enough he probably
wouldn't make a difference um say if i
knew you and you slept with him then i
think that's probably why i'd like yeah
no that's not really for me but i used
to really be against it to be fair blah
and i consider someone have someone but
if i hang around with like my friends
are good looking to look after
themselves and i just feel like why
wouldn't you fancy them weirdly enough i
wouldn't mind that more as if you'd
slept with somebody that i just feel
like he's not got no ambition he's just
like a duster doesn't really do nothing
with his life
i'd find that more putting put more off
putting than if you still wanna make my
friends overall ambitious so
yeah what would you do if i asked to see
your dms right now
newborn yeah
oh it doesn't go down in the dm's then
the mardians are dry why does it go down
then
yeah
on grilling apparently
what would you do if my ex was after you
well i wanted to beat me up yeah because
you're now with me
saying you know you have to say that l
bro you know i mean she left you i
thought his friends would be exes and
he's all cool yeah we are but what if
okay um no like at the end of the day i
wouldn't i wouldn't i try and avoid a
physical altercation at all costs
but at the end of the day if i see him
and he tries to put it on me then
if he puts his hands on me he's gonna
have to get down at that that's a new
one
i like that little heroic behavior there
by trying to avoid it all costs i've not
got time to be fighting with people in
any situation
yeah i'm 31 years old i'm not into all
that i don't mean what if i wanted to
start an only fans
absolutely not
only fans could never happen it's not
happening only fans i'm your only fan
that's all you need to know i'm your
only friend i'm the only fan you need
baby girl you wouldn't need one because
like i said i'm alpha male i take care
of you you don't need to if you're doing
it it wouldn't be for money so if it's
not for money what would it be for i
would still
whatever i'll validate you i'll make you
feel like a queen you should never want
if it's not for money you should never
want to feel to go to early transformer
because if you do i'm not doing my job
right you know what i mean that's good
um what if i got put in prison for five
years would you wait
really but would you
yeah no wait if i was if i'm in love
with you then i'm loyal to the sword you
know i mean if one of my friends went to
prison i'm not just not going to chat to
him you know me know when he gets out
like i'm a not only would you be my
point he'd be my friend my teammate you
know me and everything so i'm not gonna
wait i won't want you to go to jail i'll
probably try and take the charge for you
if anything really probably
it depends we went to jail for that
obviously you know i mean if it's
something wired up and it's something
worth spitting out for her to spit with
you but if it was
i don't know mistake or something or i
don't know something that i didn't find
out of conduct then yeah and i would
wait hundred percent yeah he'd be a
really good husband what if i didn't
want to sleep with you for the first six
months of our relationship yeah that's
calm is it yeah that's fine i don't mind
i feel like would by the time that
happens we'll get to know each other
well enough anyway and we'll have a
deeper connection and then we'll get
married
properly what would you do if i wanted
to involve other people in our sex life
that's where um first of all
um but if it wasn't
then yeah you can bring a couple of
girls in
a couple yeah not just one
couple you said other people not of
another person so
what more goes to the bedroom the more
the merrier i'm a muslim i'm allowed
four wives anyway bring them in
what if your friends were liking my
selfies
i don't i don't know i don't think you'd
i probably wouldn't notice anyway and if
i did i probably don't think nothing of
it maybe they see you as my friend me
personally i don't follow none of my
friends girlfriends on social media not
one of them a lot of them follow me and
they might like my stuff and but i don't
think nothing of it the way i say is
you're not my mate you're my friend's
missus we're not friends i'm friends
with your husband you know what i mean
well cool when i say you were nice but
i'm not going to bring you up and like
oh what are you doing should we go out
do you know obviously you're not my
friend you're my friends missus so i
don't follow them i just feel like
there's no need
she's not my friend
that's what i mean by that what would
you do if i couldn't cook
it'd be an issue but i'd teach you
what it is yeah yeah see what it is with
me
i'm i like to be babied so i like to be
looked after because i feel like that
shows a woman that she loves me when she
wants to do stuff for me care for me
yeah i feel like for you to grab your
way to do something for me you must care
about me because you wouldn't do that
otherwise whereas me
i try and make you feel good i try and
make sure you
stability taking care of things like
that because i feel like that's what a
woman would want um and i think like i
said communication if you told me what
your love languages are i'll tell you
what mine i try and cater to them the
best i can i guess if that's traditional
that's yeah she must be able to cook
then
um last one what would you do if i was
in a gang
yeah you're not inaugurating no more
gang life what is this top boy yeah no
no no we don't do that gang thing right
here she's not jack do you know what i
mean forget all that no gang stuff let's
go for a walk in the country man gang
life get out of here i've never been in
a gang in my life i feel like i guess
it's a lot to do with where you come
from and what you're exposed to and what
you know but i just feel like grow up
you know i mean a gang i know people
that have grown men in you and again go
look after your kids or go so i mean
like first of all if you're in a gang
that means you're probably involved in
drugs and violence you put yourself in a
situation now where you can get sent to
prison or killed
and if you've got a family that cares
about you why would you want to point
through that i can understand if you're
easily influenced as a kid but you're a
grown man now we didn't again so my
missus in a gang but the red bandanna
was saying that it's not happening it's
not no it's not it's not yeah what'd you
do if i was in a game no no it's not
even a wee thing yeah i'm gone yeah
that's good i agree with you do you
believe in compromise
yeah 100 our relationship can't work
without compromise because stupid
different people you know means that
they've got to be compromised to a
certain expect but how can you give me
like an example i
wanted to travel yeah and you really
wanted me to stay at home and feel like
your wife
travelling far longer like i said
everything that depends on circumstance
so who are you traveling with where
you're traveling and like say if you
want to say i want to go traveling and
you tell me you're going to have beef i
won't trust my nan in high before my
wife ain't going to die before you know
what i mean but say if you wanted to go
traveling i don't know with your friend
or because one thing is i want you to be
safe
yeah like to just go travel in the end
that's wild i wouldn't feel comfortable
because anything could happen to you but
if you wanted to go for a couple of
weeks or a certain amount of time but if
you're going for like six months then
now that's that's too much for me
you know what i mean i'll come with you
maybe we'll do that um could you forgive
cheating no no no
have you ever cheated no i've never been
in um
a situation where i would you don't put
yourself in that situation you know i
mean like i said when you're in a
relationship you should want everyone
else to be so
jealous of your wife i just don't agree
with it man i think um
yeah i just wouldn't be able to get over
it like i'd always think even if i love
you i could love you to death but if you
cheated i'd always think about that
other person and then i'd start to hate
you i might love you but i might hate
you and then it's just going to be a
toxic relationship and that's not good
for anybody could you forgive cheating
i'd say i'd like to say no at the moment
no whilst i'm young and i don't have no
commitment but i think if i was like
married
it's a different conversation because
your setup's a lot different because you
have like a mortgage you have kids
and
yeah it's not just as easy as just leave
i think also and this is not me in any
way condoning menchie and i think um
it's different from my norm to cheat i
don't i feel like a man could be
absolutely madly in love with his wife
and still cheat because it's not like a
intimate thing for a man a lot of times
it's just like he just maybe wants to
get a nut out or whatever then don't
cheat just have a wank dear like the men
and cheating thing i understand but i
don't think it's right so
that can't run with me
that's true but it could be like a man's
so perfect example i feel like say if a
man is in
a relationship with his wife and he
loves and he doesn't want to cheat but
then a supermodel gets in bed with him
and tries on with him as much as he
loves his wife and doesn't want to cheat
he's a lot more weaker to his sexual
desires than a woman so he might he
might cheat where if he's locked in a
room with away as a woman if she's like
really loves her man and they're locked
in a room together with a say her
celebrity crush she still wants you and
she
can't a man just think in that moment my
wife my kids if only not worth it
with your dick no 100 but i just feel
like
men are a lot
weaker to the desires than the females
that's why i feel like if a woman truly
loves her man she won't cheat on him
whereas i do believe that a man that
could be in love with his wife could
still cheat that's the difference i'm
not condoning it look her straight in
the eye and say no baby
i was at home last night would you even
use your sleep well then so far yeah i
get you yeah i see it
sorry how do you think you've done on
the date
i'm all right yeah i've been myself so
yeah i think we've had a good
conversation i feel like we agree on a
lot of stuff quite like nearly
everything i don't think we've had much
disagreements on anything really yeah so
i think it's a good day i've enjoyed it
now i've had a good time yeah it's been
good yeah yeah that's good i've had a
good time too you wanna see me again
yeah i'll see you again
i'm gonna go on that arcade date yeah
i'm gonna win
okay i've got
you you know what i had a really good
time but i feel like we've gone quite
well we're quite compatible i felt um i
found it very attractive we get on
hopefully she let me back we'll see you
know what i feel like he had so much
like wisdom it was so hard to grill so i
don't think he had well he handed it
well i don't think i grabbed him i don't
think she really good very much i felt
like she tried
man decoyed that he hit me quick
diversion i just went around a block and
i got home safe i feel like he's
definitely telling the truth i feel like
he's grown
a lot and i feel like there's the
difference between people that have told
me what i've wanted to hear and actually
like
doing it she's a cool girl i feel like
um i've had another date go somewhere
fun i'll smash her at arcades hopefully
she'll want to go on a third date
but yeah now 100
yeah i'll see him again go to the
arcades
do you think you're gonna meet him i'm
still i'm gonna be in do you know how
competitive i am it's hard to read
so she said that she'd like to go on a
second date with me and stuff but
whether or not that's true i don't know
i'll say probably a segment maybe a 7.5
if she's in a good mood today so i
think i'm gonna give
ty an 8.3
because i feel like we get on really
well he has got all the traditional
values that i like
and i feel there could be more chemistry
so we'll see number two
[Music]
you